imagine being as old and as impaired as
i am
and having a pretty good time
how does that happen
well you
yeah
that is another story i just tell a
couple of other stories too because you
like stories
here's an apocryphal story that is very
instructive
a young man comes to visit mozart
and he says mozart and he says i want to
write symphonies
and mozart says how old are you in the
man psalm 23.
mozart says you're too young to write
symphonies
and he says but mozart he says you were
writing symphonies when you were 10
years old
mozart says yes but i wasn't asking
other people how to do it
now there's another mozart story here's
the greatest musical talent
maybe that ever lived
and what was his life like well he was
bitterly unhappy and he died young
that's the life of mozart
what the hell did mozart do to screw it
up to make himself well he did two
things that are guaranteed to create a
lot of misery
he overspent his income
scrupulously
that's number one that is really stupid
and the other thing was he was full of
jealousies and resentments
if you'll spend overspend your income
and be full of jealousy and resentments
you can have a lousy unhappy life and
die young all you've got to do is learn
from mozart
you can also learn from
that young man who was asking mozart how
to write somebody
the truth of the matter is that
not everybody can learn everything
some people are away the hell better
and of course no matter how hard you try
they're always some guy that achieves
more
some guy or gal
and
they might answer so what
do it does any of us need to be the very
top of the whole world it's ridiculous
and
another thing that people do like bear
guard is amazing is they build these
enormous mausoleums
i think they figure they want people to
walk by that mausoleum and say gosh i
wish i were in there
anyway
you can see we've had some fun as we go
along
and it's worked so well
but if you actually figure out
how many decisions were made in the
history of the daily journal corporation
or the history of
berkshire hathaway it wasn't very many
per year
that were meaningful
it's a game of being there all the time
and recognizing the rare opportunity
when it comes and recognizing that the
normal human allotment is to
not have very many
now it's a very confident bunch of
people who sell securities who act as
though they've got an endless supply of
wonderful opportunities
those people are the equivalent of the
racetrack tout
they're not even respectable
it's not a good way to live your life to
pretend to know a lot of stuff you don't
know and pretend to furnish you
a lot of opportunities you're not
furnishing
and
my advice to you is avoid those people
but not if you're running a stock
brokerage firm you need them
but it's not the right way to make money
and and
and
this business of
of controlling the costs and living
simply and
that was the secret how much money
warren and i had tiny little bits of
money we always underspend our incomes
and we invested and we
well you know if you live long enough
you end up rich
it's not very complicated
[Music]
i had a question regarding the stoics
it's something i've read after you've
started you you actually mentioned it uh
there's a great anybody who's read your
life you're a testament to the idea that
to not be a victim but to be a survivor
and it's an attitude that has helped me
in my short
life so far could you perhaps expand on
that idea how it's helped you and how
that is perhaps one of the greatest
ways to live your life out regardless of
what happens of course
feeling like
it's really interesting to make change
some people are victimized by other
people
and if it weren't for the indignation
that that causes we wouldn't have
reforms that we need
but that truth is mixed with another
it's very counterproductive for an
individual to feel like a victim even if
he is
the best attitude is just to be careful
about everything and keep plugging along
and
therefore i don't like politicians to
get ahead by trying to make everybody
else feel like a victim
and
they make my flesh crawl
and
i just don't believe in it of course
who wants to be a victim instead of a
survivor
of course we will and but
feeling like a victim you can recognize
your position as bad and try and improve
it that's okay
but to have a deep feeling of
the one that's all somebody else's fault
is a very counterproductive way to think
people don't even like being around it
it's really stupid and yet our
politicians build on and try and make
their careers work
by doing something that's very bad for
all the people or talking to
and they think they're doing the world's
work
you know it's crazy
generally speaking
there are two things i've found in my
long life
when you never do one is never feel
sorry for yourself
if your child is dying of cancer don't
feel sorry for yourself never ever feel
sorry of yourself
the other thing you never want to have
is envy
that's the only one of the deadly sins
you're never going to have any fun at
all
pick one of the others
and
so
but if you go through life just
everlastingly plugging away
at these bad times you know kipling has
gone totally out of vote because it's
not politically correct to write lines
like a woman is only a woman with a good
cigar as a smoke
it's
and of course so nobody is familiar with
kipling but kipling's if is still great
poetry
if you can keep your mind
all about you are losing theirs just
think of what good advice that would
have been on wall street in a lot of
other places
recently
and treat the little fluctuations in
fate he said treat those two imposters
success and failure just the same
and in the end he says well if
whatever else happens you'll be a man my
son
good message
good message i mean
why not take these opportunities these
hardships and so forth
to make a man of yourself
or a person of yourself to use the
modern lingo
[Music]
[Music]
foreign